be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so what I want to
do here is have a discussion about a
mutant whose power transcends anyone
we've discussed so far including
Franklin Richards The Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Strange
in this video I want to talk about a
mutant by the name of Matthew Malloy
[Music]
still rewinding the clock back a bit the
story of Matthew Molloy takes place in
2014 during uncanny x-men vol 3 issues
23 through 31
titled the last will and testament of
Charles Xavier and actually exists as a
tie-in to the 2014 original sin event
and occurs alongside the incursions and
the end of the Marvel multiverse leading
up to Secret Wars in a 2014 interview
with Comic Book Resources Brian Michael
Bendis had stated that because of
Richard Wilson focused on the reveal of
information regarding characters from
across the Marvel Universe the idea came
to him to use original sin as a
jumping-off platform to throw out any
number of ideas regarding the various
secrets of Charles Xavier life while I
haven't been able to pinpoint an
interview where business explicitly
cites a reason for the creation of
Matthew Molloy
Howard survives in in terms of how the
story unfolds the revelation of
Matthew's existence as well as how
Xavier handle the situation provided for
a compelling story that not only
challenged cyclopses personal view of
Xavier but also challenged the way that
we as readers viewed him as well while
we won't get more in-depth into this
later since this is sketch it is better
suited within the context of the story
the other half of this coin was Avengers
vs. x-men with a 2012 crossover event
seeing the return of the Phoenix force
and its subsequent bonding with Cyclops
Namor Emma Frost's magic and Colossus
leading up to the death of Xavier at the
hands of Cyclops while the time Fitness
had taken over the uncanny x-men
following his loss of the Phoenix force
Cyclops had become increasingly more
extreme to the point that while he
maintained xavier x' ideologies
regarding a peaceful coexistence between
humans and mutants the steps he was
willing to take to achieve this peace
was more akin to the old ways of Magneto
and so what this did was wrapped back
around to the launch of uncanny x-men
with Cyclops literally fracturing the
mutant community forming his own school
called the new Charles Xavier Institute
and creating his own group composed of
Magneto Emma Frost Illyana Rasputin also
known as magic who in turn began
rallying new mutants to their side
so getting into the story of Matthew
Molloy his introduction is actually a
slow build instead of providing a
backstory for his character immediately
business instead chooses to give us
glimpses of Matthew and revolve a
majority of the first several issues
around the x-men and the last will and
testament of Charles Xavier initially
appearing unnamed Matthew was introduced
by way of what seems to be a
sister-in-law while shying away from her
attempts to speak with him as we see
pictured here Matthew isn't scared so
much for himself as he is for everyone
else the reason for this becomes
apparent when his sister in law's
continued attempts to speak with him
cause Matthew lashed out in fear
resulting in his sister-in-law as well
as everyone within a ten-mile radius
being completely annihilated to Jimmy to
the x-men with Jennifer Walters also
known as she-hulk still working as a
lawyer her arrival at the Jean Grey
school and the reveal of xavier x' will
also comes with a caveat and that
everybody who's part of the will has to
be present for its reveal because
Cyclops the school exists in a hidden
location while this presents a bit of a
challenge the true issue here is that
the x-men in jean school haven't really
faced Scott since he killed Xavier when
Cyclops killed Charles while he was in
prison for his actions he was also
broken out by Magneto and spent his
remaining time as a vigilante leading up
to the current situation now under
normal circumstances where the story
would see the x-men turning a criminal
over to the authorities within the realm
of Marvel Comics the mutant community is
largely self-contained meaning they
really like to keep things that involve
other mutants within their own house and
they don't really like involving
authorities outside of the mutant
community and their own personal affairs
and so with the x-men within the Jean
Grey school our tentative about
contacting Scott at the end of the day
they had all been brought together by
Xavier at some point over the course of
their lives and as such even if only out
of respect they all over to Xavier to
put their civil war side and meet for
this one last thing picking back up with
Matthew Bendis cracks the door open a
little further on the gravity of the
situation when Maria Hill was shield it
uses a remote device and meets Mathieu
at the site of his explosive outburst
after an unspecified amount of time
because shield exists a monitor all
threats on the planet Earth the actions
of a few did not go unnoticed the
problem with this though is that Matthew
doesn't know what
meaning that whatever power he possesses
he has no ability to control it and
doesn't understand how it works however
like most Beaton's Matthews abilities
are tied directly to his emotions which
becomes apparent when Maria Hills
interrogation pushes him too far lashing
out again after Maria Hill ordered her
soldiers to move in Matthew wipes all of
them out and destroy shield surveillance
equipment at the ground level the
picking back up with the x-men again the
story of Matthew comes into full view
when everyone is collected around
Jennifer Walters and a recording device
is played back as Charles explains when
the original x-men team was formed and
cerebro was invented as a way to both
track dangerous mutants as well as
locate potential recruits cerebro had
come across an astronomically powerful
mutant the likes of which Xavier had
never seen while he initially considered
it to be a glitch in the system or
malfunction his testing revealed that
what he was seeing was real deciding
that the best course of action was to
meet with Matthew directly by creating a
psychic illusion of himself as a child
Xavier was met with Matthew who's 8
years old at the time and is playing
outside of his home that's Matthew plays
with his toys what he does is he pits
them against one another and as they
clash Matthew unintentionally releases a
psychic backlash that seemingly destroys
his home and decimates the area
recovering from the incident
Matthew reveals to Charles that this is
the first time that this has happened
while Matthew isn't sure how it is that
he's doing this what he does reveal is
that he believes that he had killed his
parents accidentally the reason why is
that on one occasion his parents were
yelling at him at which point he simply
made them vanish whether Matthew
actually killed them or simply sent them
to another location is never explored
here but what Ben is just telling us is
that like Franklin Richards Matthew has
the ability to warp reality however as
we progress through this well actually
learn that Matthew's powers are well
beyond anything that Franklin can
achieve and so by sneaking his way into
Matthew's life as a friend Xavier was
able to make his way into Matthew's
emotional barriers and in doing so began
the slow process of erecting psychic
blocks without Matthew noticing now this
is something I'd like to focus on for a
second and the reason why is because
what this moment does is throw the
concept of Charles Xavier and what he
stands for into question what I mean
here is that Xavier is effectively
telling us that this child poses a
threat to the world and that Xavier
himself is the sole
individual capable of understanding that
threat and isolating it in truth Charles
Xavier positioned himself as the judge
jury and executioner of this child and
so what I'd like you to do is move this
idea over in the back of your heads and
as we're going through this story once
we reach the end
I'd like you to post a comment on
whether or not you think that what
Charles Xavier is doing here is right or
wrong now as time progressed Charles
Xavier maintained the psychic image of
himself as a child who would grow
alongside Matthew which served to keep
the illusion alive and allowed Xavier
the ability to continually erect psychic
barriers in Matthews mind however as
time progressed Matthew began to realize
what it was that Xavier was doing now
whether or not Matthew knew what exactly
was doing all along or simply came to
the realization one day isn't really
expanded on here and in truth it doesn't
really need to be the significance of
this moment is that Xavier was
successful in putting up mental blocks
but despite these barriers Matthew's
power was of such a scale that he was
able to deduce that this depiction of
Charles Xavier was an illusion after
casting it aside in an effort to keep
from enraging Matthew Xavier stayed so
the reason Matthew has been able to do
these things is because he's a mutant
who can draw on energies from another
dimension
and so faced with this information and
the dangers that come with it combined
with the knowledge that his inability to
control his powers resulted in the death
of his parents at the request of Matthew
Xavier finalizes the mental barriers and
places memory dampeners in Matthew's
mind removing his ability to use his
powers and in turn allowed him to forget
the fact that he is a mutant and so as
Matthew began to grow into adulthood
Xavier constantly kept a close eye on
him to ensure that the blocks were
holding and his memory was not coming
back but with Xavier dead at the hands
of Cyclops the duty now fell to the rest
of the x-men to ensure that Matthew does
not become a threat to the rest of the
world now something I'd like to focus on
here is Cyclops with Xavier requesting
that Wolverine Scott Summers and Rachel
summers gather for the purpose of
locating Matthew and monitoring him
Scott is initially against this to Scott
while he had killed Xavier the
information revealed here goes against
everything they've experienced so far
and to him the ideology of a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
was an intricate part of the x-men
philosophy that explicitly entailed
allowing mutants to decide their own
fates
by choosing to fight with or against the
x-men
to Cyclops while Xavier had been pushing
this idea on him he in turn was
violating the very principles that they
had stood for by forcing his will on to
Matthew as a result
Cyclops believes that this entire
experience with the x-men is a lie and
that Xavier himself is nothing like the
man they were led to believe now while
some of the x-men share this sentiment
at the end of the day their feeling is
that regardless of the fact that Xavier
was hiding this information this request
comes from the wish of a mentor who had
since passed and if for no other reason
the x-men should honor it for the sake
of everything that Xavier had given over
the years now transitioning back to
Matthew the following his destruction of
the shield soldiers Maria Hill had kept
her distance but also called in the help
of Exodus an omega-level telepath who
once operated as a Horsemen of
apocalypse as well as headlock a minor
hero who served as part of the West
Coast Avengers and also possesses
telepathy and the ability to cast
illusions and the minds of others
working at the request of Maria hill
Exodus attempts to enter the mind of
Matthew and while he is initially
successful once the Matthew becomes
aware of what Exodus and headlock are
doing Matthew destroys their brains and
telekinetically snaps their necks
killing them in the process a realizing
that they're up against an enemy of
extraordinary power Maria hill has the
x-men contacted in an effort to cope
with Matthew and so from here we jump
back to beast as he uses cerebro to
locate Matthew and guide the x-men to
his position now what happens next here
is extremely important as he describes
the powers of Matthew dwarf any known
mutant in existence making him beyond
omega-level now again this is extremely
important and the reason why is because
with characters like Franklin Richards
he can manipulate the existing reality
to achieve any number of feats but is
limited by the size and scope of the
reality that he's in with Matthew this
doesn't seem to be the case with both
Franklin and Matthew being mutants and
possessing the same powers because
Matthew draws on a third dimension in
order to manipulate reality the idea
here is that potentially the abilities
of Matthew are absolutely limitless in
that his ability to work reality is not
limited to the reality that he's in now
what I also want to do here is I want to
focus on the discussion between Scott
Summers and Matthew Malloy using shields
request for aid as a way to locate
Matthew the conversation between the two
is just as important for Scott Summers
as it is for Matthew Malloy with magic
looking on what Cyclops tells Matthew is
that he and Cyclops have a lot in common
allowing Matthew to read his mind
Cyclops reveals that as a child his
power of optic blasts manifested itself
in a way that had an irreparable impact
on his life the reason why I wanted to
focus on this conversation is that what
this does is give us an insight into the
world of Cyclops regarding how he views
Xavier on a personal level and how he
views the world as a whole to Cyclops
Xavier was a father figure
but more so than that as the years
passed and he was recruited to the x-men
while the roster changed and expanded
with new members the message of Xavier
stood the test of time while there were
struggles the issue Cyclops faced was
that when the Avengers save the world
everyone cheered but when the x-men
saved it humanity's hatred always won
out as a result
Cyclops didn't become bitter of the year
so much as he began to become frustrated
unlike Charles Xavier however Cyclops
allowed his resentment to get the best
of him and while he doesn't say it
looking beyond the pages a legitimate
argument could be made that Cyclops
killing Xavier during Avengers vs. x-men
was in response to his anger over the
fact that Xavier was never willing to do
what it took to force humanity to accept
mutants however something I'd like you
to notice here in the writing of this
story so far is that Brian Michael
Bendis has effectively been writing
himself into a corner because his story
takes place during the events of time
runs out the Avengers and the Fantastic
Four aren't part of the picture because
they're dealing with the collapse of the
multiverse the Inhumans are dealing with
the destruction of Attilan following the
events of infinity as well as the
Terrigen mists spreading throughout the
world and waking up new Inhumans what
dennis is doing here is basically
eliminating all the ways that Matthew
could be defeated with the exception of
one this reason that bend is selected is
considered by many fans to be a cardinal
sin of comic books
what ventus does here is invoke
time-travel as a way to end a story what
we find here is that during the
conversation between Cyclops and Matthew
with magic watching it all unfold that
shield suddenly responds with a
bombardment of missiles attacking the
area
because of the fact that Matthew wasn't
able to respond in time and even if he
could he couldn't control his powers and
because Illyana Rasputin stability to
manipulate various magics is not
advanced enough to allow her to shield
herself or everybody else from the
destruction the result here is that
everybody Cyclops magic and Matthew
Malloy are completely incinerated by the
shield attack and so with Matthew
resurrecting himself after his
destruction at the hands of shield while
all of this is happening one of
cyclopses students a girl named tempest
travels into the past and meet Charles
Xavier
prior to his death during Avengers vs.
x-men the side track here for a second
Tempest is a girl named Eva Belle and
was discovered by Cyclops following his
departure from the rest of the x-men and
after the formation of the new Xavier
school as a mutant who he controlled
time IVA does this by creating what are
called temporal bubbles initially she
was only able to stop time within the
sphere of those bubbles but was able to
expand them up to the size of his city
as time progressed though and her
abilities expanded with training at the
hands of Illyana Rasputin Tempest was
eventually able to travel and forward
through time by using one of her bubbles
using this ability tempest uses her time
with Charles Xavier to effectively and
Matthew Molloy wrapping this event up
over the course of a page and a half
Eva's explanation of the circumstance
involving Matthew's inability to control
his powers have led Charles to take
action by traveling to where Matthew
Malloy's parents first met using his
powers Xavier deters Matthew's father
for meeting his mother and as a result
Matthew simply ceases to exist now at
the same time this is happening but
prior to Xavier actions Matthew arrives
at the Jean Grey school following the
death of Cyclops and magic in an effort
to seek help from Emma Frost and the
rest of the x-men on how to control his
powers
however because beasts had been
monitoring the life signs of Cyclops and
magic prior to their deaths but was
unable to detect the shield assault the
belief of the x-men is that laughs you
had killed him with Emma Frost lashing
out in anger towards Matthew his
inability to control his powers comes
into play when he accidentally
obliterates Emma Frost entirely with the
x-men responding in kind they view
Matthew as an enemy and as a result
launch an attack against him
simultaneously
however because Matthew has such extreme
powers here
instinctively and in doing so wipes out
all of the x-men but with Charles Xavier
using his abilities in the past to keep
Matthew's parents from meeting the
result is that everything in this story
is treated as if it had never happened
since Matthew had never existed now what
I want to do here is I want to talk
about this ending and the reason why is
because for comic fans this ending
represents everything wrong with
time-travel and comics for comic readers
time travel has always been a quagmire
in that more often than not
whenever creators write themselves into
a corner the way Bendis did here whether
they coming up with unique ways to get
out of it
time travel is invoked which results in
an otherwise incredible story falling
flat on its face in truth time travel is
a concept that can be used appropriately
such as Hitman's run in Fantastic Four
and that it wasn't used to end the story
so much as it was to enhance the
importance of Franklin Richards and the
lights that he would go to in order to
save his family however in this instance
comic readers tend to look at this
ending and simply write it off as a
perfect example of lazy storytelling
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later peace